to celebrate Lunar New Year with their
year of the rabbit menu specials here to
tell us more is Chef Maul from said
noodles which is inside the Palms Resort
oh everybody hi Dixie how are you it's
good to see you yes thank you so what
goes into planning a menu for the year
of the rabbit
those the plan for us because the spring
coming up yeah so that's why our planet
have the menu changing so basically we
are
it's every six months or eight months we
have the menu changes changing things
out of season yeah kind of look at the
season what is good for that summer time
what's good for the winter time so the
winter time it's colder when we get into
the soup here that you have first but
the Chinese New Year started on the 22nd
okay okay so it's 22nd is first day of
the year that's caused the year and so
here we are in the day two of the New
Year yes and listen I'm super excited
because you we're making what kind of
super did you bring here today so today
we bring the teens and so this is the
ginsen we have different
from China Korean American but we are in
the American so that's why we used
American let the people know we still
have Jesus from America like a gene
teacher yeah okay
big difference yeah so that's what we
have over here yeah these are the
ingredients so that's ingredients so
this is the slice already side up so
that's usually pickle the root is big
piece one there so this is always like
the roots also but it's the end okay
so this one you should use make a basic
the bra this is the bra so all that goes
in here it smells great it's nutritious
too this is a healthy soup what are some
of the meats I've seen so we have the
ham chicken boom
of course we have the
the children wrote inside you can see it
outside and how long is this Stewie how
long is it so you basically we make this
a two to four hours depends on how big
two to four hours it's a cold day
outside I'm gonna try something this is
already done yeah this is just it smells
great it's nice and warm let's see here
there's so much flavor yes in this soup
it's warming me up right now basically
we have a full uh if you want the flavor
oh my gosh anything yes that is real
quick too we gotta wrap it up but
there's entertainment happening as well
yes we have a line dance and the Dragon
Dance on the January 28th the
traditional Dancing Yeah Chef Mo thank
you so much for joining us this was a
pleasure and happy New Year my friend
Happy New Year and also we had the whole
week like coming up at the in the Palms
where uh Cena Vista has a Chinese also
over I don't know if you have the kanji
and the dim sum and also Ace Buffet we
have the whole week about the Chinese
and the menu coming up and the big day
was a January 20th it's a Asian okay I
love it I gotta wrap it up thank you so
much Julian we're gonna send it over to
you